dude I'll apologize - well it's waiting
I I'm just gonna wait now what we've
known each other a while yeah one reason
I'm in stand-up comedy I mean just no
nice in a little while yeah how long
that we know I don't know what you're we
in 2019 2012 yeah seven years I see more
than I see anyone else on this planet
yeah I know we've talked to you more
than anybody in the world yeah who's
Bryan Callen that'd be you yeah but
who's the Bryan count on the special
thanks on the end credits yeah that's a
different branch okay have you never met
him I haven't met the guy he spells it
brii and right now fear why and because
I felt like I would I deserve this slot
in it - I thought there give you a
picture yeah Alice yeah I closed without
the story of I against a comic sure
and somehow they decided they go hey who
do you want for the special thanks I
said wife see Rogan Callen Feldman
Justin ed Brooke yeah and then what yeah
Bert Kreischer yeah yeah no doubt and
then they spelled your name wrong how
humble dude I was so mad when when you I
know you hate me that yeah you're so
detailed I just kept getting texts from
people you know I don't give a [ __ ] but
it was just so funny and then I all I
said was I said butt beat Brian sent a
picture of it but Brian Brian would go
around there who's Brian and and I just
got Jesus Christ I was so mad I said
talusan how the [ __ ] who did this how's
this happen out of all them how's this -
yes how do you know about the end but at
the same time now you sleazy fixer but I
cannot associate with me and know the
things I do and then I send my list with
the correct spelling obviously I don't
know if you spell your name Bri and suck
a dick it should be be ry a in and I
send it to them who would just like oh
it's Brian and when you know the history
of yeah how crazy is well you know
people you know people do it how does
Game of Thrones leave it leave out a cup
of coffee on those
creditors same editors same head of guys
just missing [ __ ] way to go guy name
of Thrones way to jaws special he
misspelled Brian's name you busy
wait asleep there was plastic water
bottles on and final on sense now that's
a lot of stuff shaking up I'll get to a
beloved's fake Paris yeah [ __ ] in when
you see my back rip I pull myself up
like a champ like a champ through 30
times fast while talking to you why
wouldn't I give that to you as it's a
gif it's a gift it's a gift